c'erano lavori da un uomo gay una donna
del sud due uomini etero pianti chi
spende e per facilitarci chiameremo lo
stronzo e la b spa teresa un avvocato
non
biodegradabile una ragazza che non aveva
più nulla da perdere un poveretto in
cerca di fama è un dolce molti noble
dozo città eterna la più alta in
concentrazione di beni storici
architettonici al mondo roma porta
dentro di sé le testimonianze di quasi
tre millenni di civiltà
simboli di questa città sono la lupa il
colosseo il cupolone e le curve profonde
irregolari delle buche per strada che ti
fanno saltare le ruote non appena brandi
la macchina a roma sono tutti i suoi
sensi
una boccata d'aria carica di storia
cultura e puzza di merda proveniente dai
numerosi sacchi di spazzatura sparsi ad
arte in ogni anno della città il suono
il river che scorre accompagnato dal
canto delle campane delle chiese dalle
bestemmie che i romani ti lanciano
addosso nel tentativo di fraternizzare
roma ed è la sua tradizione ebraica con
le sue paste famose in tutto il mondo
dalla libia alla carbonara
la roma è anche l'uomo vicino gli
animali non è raro infatti vedere
persone camminare per i fori in
compagnia e un ratto grande quanto una
smart uno stormo di gabbiani che cerca
di strappare il cibo dalle mani
ho un gruppo di cinghiali che avevano
voglia di fare un salto al centro
storico signore e signori su per voi
roma
la bomba
proprio bene
buongiorno ragazzi allora stiamo
partendo siamo a roma questa qui un
pochino diciamo giocare in casa possiamo
dirlo
ragazzi siamo a roma come sede di alla
guida c'è la nostra graziana mi ha fatto
notare una cosa praticamente si è
installata la slitta di babbo natale a
pechino che per entrare di tali
indicazioni per tutto dicembre dopo giro
a destra graziano ha fatto venire voglia
di installarlo nella mia macchina
correre a 200 chilometri orari e
lanciarmi e farle situate nella macchina
in corsa
[Musica]
questo qui che cos'è il palazzaccio
voglio dire questa cosa perché sono
molto orgogliosa è la sede del consiglio
dell'ordine degli avvocati di roma che è
l'alto al quale io sono iscritta ma
dentro credo di avere una moto di questa
epoca
dagherrotipo cos'è che devi giurare di
applicare la legge rampa con etica con
proprietà go di unità che
cos'è che poi si dimentica tutto questo
e granata guarda ci troviamo al
gianicolo punto bello alto di roma che
mi permette di avere un bel vedere
furto
ma
si vede tutto umili e modesti come solo
noi romani sappiamo essere ogni giorno a
mezzogiorno in punto spariamo un bel
colpo di cannone a salve
ricordare che la città eterna sveglia
all alba
dire come sai
racconta
successo non so quanti romani o in
generale conosco io per esempio una
conosco ma non l'ho mai in vita mia ma
per andare in una via che si chiama
piccolomini tv è una strada che va
dritta e dritto c'è san pietro la
prospettiva vuole che se ti avvicini
alla cupola è la sensazione che si
allontani e se ti allontani dalla cupola
e la tentazione che si avvicina
rappresentazione visiva di romeni vorrai
e tini febbraio vorrei e più stare con
te e anche le nostre nota con se ne
deriva secondo me dei social sembrano
tutti belli tutti cupolone può invece da
visita
di
più un piccione volevo dire il gabbiano
ma ragazzi ma chi è che mi vuole
regalano a casa qui ci sono sempre farmi
questo piccolo presente
[Musica]
andiamo all'estero abbiamo toccare la
mamma mia ma qual è il punto quello del
colonnato aspettano a quello che si
vedono solo una colonna gravissima il
nostro caro amico gian lorenzo bernini
giallo perché è arrivato questo effetto
ottico che se ti piazzi in un punto vedi
solo una una colonna con scheletri
perché andiamo cercando signor carlo la
mia ti seguo questa è la ripresa lenta
sguardo
si no
mia enorme e
quella materia dell'orrore degli alberi
di natale
usciamo quanto tutti gli alberi natale
solo l'un per cento degli alberi di
natale è veramente bello il resto sono
patetici noi è bellissimo di albero di
natale invece no è solo banale e poi
alcuni sono veramente brutti e l'avevo
detto la magia con l'acqua sembra tutto
quanto una sola colonna italia tre stati
lo stato italiano tra marino e il
vaticano san marino non sia potuto
l'eurovision a2 della marina non sanno
va dalla gara risalti gianmarco mi ha
appena aperto gli occhi una barca
presenta ma che ne so ma se vede che la
barca che è un barcone di migranti di
ogni epoca in piazza san pietro
ma alla meraviglia castel sant'angelo
guarda qui il ponte negli occhi di parah
parah parah parah parah
marmi detto che tu lo conosci il dette
mastro titta pasta fonte gli ho detto no
a sant'angelo era una prigione quando il
boia mastro titta attraversava il ponte
qualcuno stava per lasciarci le penne
significa sta per accadere una cosa
indebita
[Applauso]
chi è il liceo nel quale la parte giusta
della nostra famiglia è venuto a
studiare il resto parlano tutti quanti
cani che con verità con un posto così
doveva essere bellissimi ricordi troppo
fascista per quanto mi riguarda hanno
fatto il classico
classico adesso andiamo a mangiare la
pizza al taglio che tipico streetfood
romano agostino ti rende compagnia
andiamo alla
fai la progressista
l'universalità di questo pezzo di storia
corso trieste quindi con agostino di
base non ha conosciuto mai roma semmai
un prezzo di fissa
questa l'assaggio visto nel vedere se è
giusto antisale
come di tale
devo dargli un paio di altri morti
[Musica]
hai detto che cos'è simile alla palla
diviso napoletano io apprezzo napoli
napoletani ma a volte creazione faccia
delle degli scivoloni imperdonabili
la vista e patata è più buona di roma
l'unico telefono che si chiama rispondo
con appetito è meritato un morso uno e
morto e io è il boccone più buono di
solito l'approccio per ultima quindi
dovevo parlare qual è la migliore
mangiate dalla una cosetta durante
quella che vi stiamo per far vedere i
ragazzi è un infarinatura di roma non si
può vedere in un giorno così come was
built in a day che ha un attimo quindi
di aprire la mente se siamo dei romani
se non sede di roma c'è anche altra roba
quello che faremo a partire a piazza del
popolo e farci lucino del centro insieme
anche a un ospite d'eccezione di
eccezione questo dolce
possiamo dirlo 15 roma non è milano per
esempio oggi la spazzatura c'è perché
tutta una montagna di monnezza non
facciamo vedere cioè siamo tutti nel
senso
queste
[Musica]
riprendo il caso
veramente bello
non l'hai non l'hai ripreso che cosa vi
ha aderito anche la scalinata calcio
sono belle le donne di roma
la barcaccia sia stata strutturata in
questa maniera quindi sotto i livelli
della terra proprio perché l'acquedotto
che c'è qua sotto non aveva abbastanza
potenza per farlo a tampinare facendo
una fontana ad altezza normale comunque
oggi da lavinia alla guida è un attimo
il predator ha appena detto se qui e il
posto dove si lanciavano alla finale
detto mi sono confuso avere un attimo è
stato la stessa non ce la faccio lirico
accudisca estensione ha detto nomi sono
conclusi sembra non solo pervertito
sembra pure ignorante che ho a premi ma
le donne di roma
[Musica]
ora che il negozio i predator io passo
per il pervertito l'ignorante e mo il
senatore
sì perché sono dietro giocatori ma
tantissima
ha fatto la sua gemella isabella
[Risate]
memoria che stella amore è giusto per
salvaguardare la mia immagine volevo
dire andiamo a quella piazza in cui si
lanciano le monetine
[Musica]
visto che coaching era andata male
vorrei lancerà moneta ma la domanda è
deve scendere giù ma si può lanciare
anche la sopra la moneta
qua è più facile fa centro rispetto al
porco di firenze la puntina fontana e
che si è visto fermento
rometti democratica di equa lancia la
moneta firenze infilano nel suino dopo
che li na pagare accarezzasse prega di
su che cada nel tombino che grosso così
cioè
[Musica]
no
a
non sapevo che le fontane di roma queste
si chiamassero nasoni nardone capisci
perché
noi la nato ne destinazione parenti non
basta non fa più ridere
allora siamo al pantheon è uno dei miei
posti preferiti a roma una dei miei
probabili case che vorrei avere ma
quello
il punk avere una casa qua vista sul
canton quindi ragazzi per favore
iscriviti a questo canale ma va
permettermi di comprare un domani casa
qui al punt al mittente un pollice in su
ogni quali censure un euro tu
non avrai mai una casa fatta di sette
amici che forse era prendere a new york
[Musica]
sopra queste piazze grandi e famose non
ci vivrei my
family e parte le quattro studio
rappresentano quattro fiumi di quali
quello ammantato è il nilo un altro che
c'ha pure che caschi la chiesa davanti
anche se una leggenda che se tipo
bernini che progetto della fontana a
screziato è la prima forma di dissing
nei confronti borromini che aveva fatto
la chiesa proprio diventate mila ma
anche il mio fidanzato non c'è quello
pauroso che non lo voglio tuia la prima
forma di mascherina come io uscivo
all'inizio dei colli con un panno in
testa e l'agenzia di arrivare
però gli voglio bene adorabile anche se
è orribile piena siamo arrivati ai
disperati validissimi resteranno ok
ma io pensavo che il telaio fosse un
aggettivo lì davanti c'è un albero di
natale
correndo che conferma la mia teoria
sugli alberi di natale spell anch'io
questa signora albero e cozza più legata
tua hai presente le macchine dei coatti
so pieni di led e luci avere tante luci
e vuol dire essere bello manca solo una
cosa il monumento più importante del
mondo lo so che lo stato non avremo
ancora c'è un altro pezzo a far vedere
una piccola lista bellissima ma da dove
mentre si va al corso
[Musica]
murdoch è un campione si è fatto tutto
il tempo a scorrazzare per roma era la
versione zombie di un carrello avesse
avuto un contapassi un approccio non so
quante calorie
qualcuno può prenderli in braccio anche
a me sa che carino
enrico che porta in braccio alessandro
una delle cose più gruppi che abbia mai
visto nella mia vita stiamo veramente
andando in uno dei miei posti preferiti
a roma invece son limonato in passato
uno molto un contesto romantico ho fatto
una delusione proprio uomo ha letto un
cocente il bel ricordo del posto
cancellando il protagonista paolo dei
due fori almeno è stato piacevole vuol
dire i due fari e stato piacevole
esatto molto è corretto concorda altro
che milano ragazzi questa città è
stupenda ed eli nominata malissimo non
spendano un euro per l'illuminazione
buio quindi peggio di milano di
illuminazione milano forse meglio se non
è
marina con una battuta sempre comprato
all'odio ma in realtà no a milano sono
abbastanza finora invece certo come in
altre zone d'italia ecco se lo dici su
roma
buttiamola la roma è un cantiere lavori
in riga basta finiamo list i lavori due
anni dopo
ma andava a vedere conosciamo magari
hanno pure levate s transenne no no e
c'erano un mese fa
e chi ci ha portato al in un articolo
mezzo girato che ho detto una donna ma
lascia in classico
come alessandro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dopo non so quanto camminare siamo
arrivati davanti al colosseo potrebbe
non aver bisogno di spiegazioni ma una
cosa interessante quando è stato creato
davanti aveva il colosso e non era stata
enorme molto ovviamente saranno la m z
troveranno un certo punto e colosse
fermeranno gli scaricò fecero una testa
di 100 giorni per celebrare l'apertura
del colosseo una volta andai in america
mi dissero guarda ed era tipo un tutto
un castello antico bellissimo sentire
quando è stato fatto non lo so due anni
fa ma perché l'hanno costruito e jahvè
cadavere l'antichità senza bisogno di
finger la l'american ce l'hanno nissin
all'america così bella gradevole tanto
però anche andare a mangiare io non
vengo a cena ragazzi
segreto
mangerà anche lui
[Musica]
ecco l'arrivo calcoli è pronta e pronta
ma è solo l'inizio per lei anche il
minatore di pecorino
mi è cascato un fagiolo sulle palle
adesso nei tre a livello di grandezza
vogliamo che non miracolato risponde
[Musica]
antipasto sapida però buonissima maliane
preferita
hai preso il secondo
letterina velo graziate
diamo il dolce
regolari
tiramisù
ragazze gratis i fari masoni a dice
letta
[Applauso]
ed è così che questa puntata del vioxx
finisce qui tra supplì cani stanchi e
desideri finalmente alterati per voi che
avete avuto le palle di resistere fino a
questo punto grazie ragazzi avete
stomaco da vendere e un po strettino
però a me non mi voglio far vedere una
cosa
ti paia di gambe sinistra
adesso però uscite scopate divertiti e
se li voglio bene ti dici tanto
sognata luttazzi e al prossimo video